MH so now the rap Young Thug this rapper
Who's going away for a long time here I
think they are now going to use his
lyrics against him in
prosecution this is something that has
been happening lyrics can be used as
evidence during rapper Young Thugs trial
on gang and racketeering charges let me
catch everybody up to speed that isn't
aware of
this in
rap people rap about crimes they
committed sometimes and a lot of those
crimes are very very accurate like they
literally say exactly what they
did and now prosecutors are able to take
those lyrics and say this is not you
don't have this artistic license you're
describing uh something that happened in
visceral detail and we're going to use
it against you here is my message to the
RAP
Community as a whole because I have some
advice and you might look at me and go
wait a minute you don't have advice I do
um and this is uh this is my message for
the people in the community of drill rap
and other types of
rap if you kill Frank on Sixth Street
let's just say
that why not say you killed Bill on 8th
Street I'm not saying probably Frank and
Bill are not the names of the people
that are involved in this perhaps I'm
just in my own head to keep it straight
if you and I don't want to sound racist
here but you're going to sound racist by
just saying what I'm going to say but
it's not racist it's just I'm trying to
approximate this okay if if you kill
dquan in the Bronx say you killed
Rosario in
Queens make it up you don't have to be
that I know it's
credibility if you say the actual guy
you don't H you can just fudge
it it's you can fudge it I know people
have gotten very comfortable now where
they could just literally go on and talk
about a h a murder they committed but
they are all the cop they are listening
so just fudge
it go around
it throw people for a loop throw them
for a loop you know use fake names use
fake locations you could still get the
message across is my point my point is
you can still get the message across you
don't have to be glaringly accurate
about every murder that you've committed
every single murder that you've
committed you're going to be accurate
you like yeah we right outside of
the bodega on 17th I shot him in the
head and it's like hey hey he he he hey
hey hey
hey say it's the fish spot on
79th and you could have a fun little
chart in the room when you're writing
Rhymes you could go I said what did we
really do well we shot this guy outside
of the bodega changed Bodega to fish
spot and say we shot a
woman what about that that'll really
that'll throw everybody for Loop but you
have to lie you have to lie like
comedians will'll make stuff up
sometimes people make stuff up not me
others my point is that a judge has said
that lyrics will be admissible as
evidence in the trial of star us rapper
Young Thug
a lot of people are not into it it's
been decried by Free Speech groups like
Jay-Z and Coldplay I love Coldplay
Coldplay is like don't use our lyrics
don't use our lyrics to call us
like cplay somehow involved in
this don't you dare use lyrics against
people you might listen to our songs and
think we're but that's not true
don't use our
lyrics there's a lot of people going
down right now 28 people were initially
charged including uh another chart
topping rapper gunana Who's got great
music I love all of their music by the
way and the way I feel and this is a
controversial thing
but I say let sleeping dogs lie and
here's what I mean by this can't
everyone start with a fresh
slate like they should go to a lot of
these rappers go okay The Killing stops
now and then if they don't kill anymore
it's like okay because it's part of the
thing it's part of the game I don't
condone
it prosecutor Simone Hilton quoted
lyrics in court quote I just beat a
murder rap I paid my lawyer 30 for that
there's a few other lyrics in between
that and then me and my slimes are above
the law well people you
know yeah well this is the thing this is
why you have to start rapping about the
cops being good throw everyone for a
loop throw them for a loop you can still
do The Killing you can still go out
there and do the killing and throw
everyone for a loop Eric Adams is the
man the cops are who I
stand you know it ain't easy to be a
cop you know like it may maybe that
maybe that's the move maybe like you go
the other way if you're a real Gangster
and you're ordering hits and killing
people maybe you go the other way and
just do do the Candace Owens thing
Candace Owens could be ordering hits all
over the hood we' never know we would
never
know so that might be the move that
might be the move the move might be the
more violent you are actually you just
stay very like you
know Pro cops you know their new song
that they're coming out with um which is
I don't know if this is a little suspect
but Young Thug's new song Israel has a
right to defend
itself
feels
I don't know it just feels you know
slightly a little patronizing perhaps a
little opportunistic young thug and
gun's new song Israel has the right to
defend itself shalom